i
[Música]
e
unidos cada vez más a esta emisión de
canadá en las américas café del programa
que les proponemos desde la sección en
español del radio canadá internacional
cada viernes a la misma hora claro que
eso depende del lugar en que se
encuentran ustedes porque la hora
canadiense cambio precisamente el último
fin de semana ahí vemos imágenes de
distintos lugares de este enorme país el
segundo territorio en extensión en el
mundo después de rusia que ya está
entrando lentamente en la época invernal
sí ya mí me llamó detención cerca de mi
casa yo vivo en la ribera sur de
montreal cruzando la avenida trasero que
es una de las más importantes de esa
zona los jardines de las casas que
estaban del otro lado de la avenida está
avanzado totalmente cubiertos de blanco
de nieve y en el sector en el que yo
vivo no porque hay sol que está en el
lado soleado el sol o que el famoso
soleado
bueno estuve trabajando todo en la
ciudad de quebec
ya estaba blanca [ __ ] la llama blanca
de los jardines
todavía hablo en cualquier idioma no no
todavía este las calles y las veredas
pero todos los jardines están cubiertos
de blanco ya estamos ahí está hueco
o no tan lentamente según el gusto de
leonardo pero poco a poco nos vamos
metiendo ya en el invierno una vez más
el invierno que después se prolonga
durante unos cuantos meses y es parte de
la realidad de este país los saludamos
entonces a todos ustedes les agradecemos
una vez más estar presentes a través de
las diversas plataformas en las que se
encuentran disponible en nuestra emisión
es decir a través de nuestro sitio en
internet www designer punto sea a través
de la página de facebook live y a través
por supuesto del canal de youtube donde
semana a semana nos va siguiendo cada
vez más
gente hoy estamos aquí en el estudio
leonardo jiménez leonardo gimeno
efectivamente pablo barrios y muy
agradablemente sorprendido de ver que
estoy cercado de argentino
somos mayoría absoluta va a estar un
poco más tarde paloma martínez también
justo ahora le confirmaron una
entrevista que estaba esperando desde
primera hora de la mañana y les ayudo
justo cuando se encaminaba para venir al
estudio pero en pocos minutos va a estar
con nosotros mi nombre es luis laborda y
además ustedes ya lo escucharon hablar
en la otra punta de la mesa tenemos un
invitado que es damián nisenson que es
entre otras cosas porque parece ser que
es multifacético es músico es un viejo
conocido del radio canadá internacional
estado más de una ocasión aquí yo
honestamente no me crucé nunca con vos
cómo te lo decíamos el otro día hablando
mucho con dos pero hay hay hay pruebas
de que has estado en más de una ocasión
yo le recordaba justamente a damián que
una vez hicimos una emisión en las raras
veces que salíamos de los estudios de
acá de radio canadá internacional
y esa vez salimos para el salón del
libro que se hizo en esa ocasión en la
plaza banquillo normalmente y entonces
pues allí tuvimos la ocasión de que
limitamos a damián y el vino y estuvo
tocando su saxofón ahí en esa ocasión sí
que lo recuerda como un momento muy
agradable fue perfecto así que repitamos
los libros en estos días
también ha estado con presentaciones
residentes tiene otras más programadas
en el corto plazo tiene una gira
prevista también hubo actuaciones
previstas para comienzos del año próximo
en argentina de donde es originario
aunque hace muchos años ya que se fue
del país en pocos instantes más vamos a
hablar con él de su actividad presente
pasada y futura también pero como es
habitual vamos a comenzar nuestro
espacio semanal con un tema destacado de
toda la actividad que nos ocupa semana a
semana y en este caso pablo estábamos
hablando de esta mañana
de un proyecto de reforma de intención
del gobierno provincial aquí en la
provincia de québec de reformar una ley
que afecta particularmente a los
trabajadores ex trabajadores a las 12
radiantes extranjeras a los trabajadores
a las lavadoras temporales también en
este caso la discusión parecería que se
ha centrado más en el tema de los
estudiantes hablamos de un programa que
beneficiaba a aquellos estudiantes que
llegaban a estudiar aquí desde el
exterior y que guardaban o guardan aún
la esperanza de poder en el futuro
cercano permanecer en quebec y en canadá
y logrando su residencia permanente
el programa se llama es el programa de
la experiencia quebequense es un
programa con el que el gobierno de la
provincia de québec ha atraído desde
hace ya cierto tiempo
estudiantes extranjeros para que
vinieran a cursar sus estudios aquí en
la provincia de québec hay que decir que
los estudiantes extranjeros pagan un
buen precio por venir a estudiar acá el
que sea
en un curso de formación profesional o
una carrera universitaria o cualquier
otra ahora ese es el programa de
experiencia que ve que se ve viene o
venía acompañado de este anzuelo del que
decíamos que ese es el certificado de
selección de que el certificado de
selección de quebec
se expide una vez que el estudiante ha
terminado su curso de estudios acá y le
permite tener acceso a la ciudadanía
canadiense de una forma acelerada y tres
años puede tenerlo lo que no ocurre pues
con el tipo de inmigración como la que
nosotros hicimos que bueno a mí me tocó
cinco años antes después yo pedí mi
ciudadanía un poco más tarde pero en esa
época había que estar cinco años y no
más que seis meses no más de seis meses
fuera del país para poder pedir la
ciudad más tarde los plazos se acortaron
cuando yo vine llegué con mi certificado
de selección en el bolsillo con mi
presencia permanente de hecho en el
bolsillo y exactamente novecientos
setenta y cinco días después pude
iniciar el trámite de la ciudadanía pero
lo cierto es que más allá de los plazos
que a veces estira no se acortan según
las necesidades y las políticas vigentes
el certificado de selección es la
antesala a poder solicitar más tarde la
llaga de la grave
la puerta sino y aparte gran parte del
trámite cuando uno lo hace aparte fuera
digamos de este sistema o del sistema
que estamos hablando ahora uno lo hace a
fuerte otro
luismi certificado selección y si un
trámite que duró aproximadamente año y
medio en argentina hasta que me dieron
de ahí empecé y de ahí pude venir y
después tres años más para la ciudadanía
con ciertas condiciones como por ejemplo
no salir cierta cantidad de tiempo en
este caso hay muchísima gente que
aprovecha está este tipo de planos de
estos programas y viene yo conozco una
persona que le contaba el otro día pablo
cuando discutíamos este tema
es una persona está estudiando un
un programa muy específico de dibujo
técnico para para entrar a trabajar en
las industrias y esta persona me contaba
que
un 70 a 80 por ciento de la gente que
está ahí
es gente que viene de afuera son
inmigrantes que pagan una fortuna pero
para justamente acelerar la posibilidad
de poder entrar cosa que le conviene los
dos al inmigrante que está formándose
para poder salir a trabajar que tiene un
título inmediatamente después de
terminar este curso que puede acelerar
su trámite y al mismo tiempo al
instituto que cobra un dinero muy
importante y ese dinero lo reinvierte
para las formaciones entonces realmente
es un círculo que beneficiaba a los dos
hasta ahora nuestro invitado de damián
se sale de la vaina por opinar sobre el
tíbet como inmigrante como esposo de un
inmigrante estudiante universitaria que
ya es canadiense pero conociendo bien el
palo no conociendo bien el tema para mí
es muy difícil de entender la decisión
de este gobierno con respecto a los
estudiantes porque
yo los considero los inmigrantes ideales
es gente que ya ha vivido acá durante
años que ya se ha construido de alguna
manera una vida decir que se ha
insertado en la realidad local y que
funciona bien en esa realidad pero
obligado por los estudios además ya
tiene un manejo más que bueno de la
lengua por un lado por el otro lado un
enorme porcentaje de sus estudiantes son
franceses porque que tiene no sólo del
punto de vista sentimental pero legal
acuerdos específicos los específicos con
francia que hace que un porcentaje
enorme los estudiantes extranjeros a que
sean ya francófonos no es muy difícil de
entender si no es viéndolo con una
especie de obsesión ideológica para
contentar a su base porque una parte de
la base de la que convengamos es de
derecha es miedosa xenófoba
sin querer exagerar pero la vista se ha
manifestado de hecho expresamente a
favor de reducir las cuotas de
inmigración y aquí cabe señalar muy
particularmente que este este es un
nuevo gobierno que está que asumió hace
entonces y que reemplazó al gobierno
liberal hay que señalar también que la
inmigración es muy importante para este
país porque el índice de envejecimiento
de la población es muy alto y en la tasa
de natalidad es muy baja entonces tienen
que contar con la inmigración para poder
compensar de alguna cabeza ese desfile a
eso se le suma a las necesidades del
mercado laboral en más de una ocasión se
ha expresado a favor de incrementar las
cuotas para satisfacer o para remediar
mejor dicho la carencia de mano de obra
que existen muchísimos sectores algunos
de ellos de gran importancia dentro de
lo que es el aparato económico
provincial e incluso
y que parecería que han sido excluidos
de esta iniciativa no hay perdón no
agraviando las las listas justamente de
profesiones aceptadas o recomendadas de
cosas ridículos por ejemplo la industria
a focas ya la industria oriental a
forestal no está incluida el 100 por
ciento de la gente que se recibe en la
liga si este de quebec en abbey típica
de mis camas son extranjeros todos
encuentran empleo en la región siendo
que justamente la permanencia de jóvenes
en región es uno de los más graves
tenemos no hay manera de entender lo que
el gobierno está haciendo si no es con
este trasfondo ideológico y además el
hecho de hacer algo tan grave proponer
algo tan grave que todo el mundo va
reaccionar cómo fue este uso retroactivo
de la ley todo el mundo se volvió loco
con eso lo cual hace que para mucha
gente ahora la ley pase ellos
retrocedieron con la retroactividad pero
ahora nos hacen tragar el sapo para gay
se da igual porque lo que lo que sucedió
fue que sea
una bola la plata sola los estudiantes
fueron a la asamblea nacional de québec
protestaron los partidos de la oposición
los apoyaron y bueno crearon todo un
bolo lo que hizo que al día siguiente el
ministro de inmigración de que becks
saliera la primera cosa que hizo en la
mañana puede decir bueno que no eran tan
abiertos escuchamos lo que nos dicen y
vamos a cambiar un poquito se acuerdan
de las 18.000 demandas de inmigración
la misma estrategia presentamos una
aberración retroceden sobre la
aberración pero lo más importante que
querían hacer pasar paso y yo nos
enteramos estar así que ojo exacto eso
lo que están haciendo con este programa
de experiencia quebequense que bueno con
el bolo lo que se formó le dijeron bueno
que está bien los que ya están aquí
serán aceptados hay una cláusula de
excepción para que ellos no tengan que
retirarse e irse
pero la ley pasa de todas formas para el
futuro se aplica y demás ya que hay que
decirlo también el hecho de que puedan
acceder es decir este programa surgió
nació hace 10 años aproximadamente
apuntaba inicialmente a los estudiantes
de los últimos niveles a quienes estaban
ya prontos a recibirse en el último año
o último año y medio de estudios dos
años como máximo y servía además de
anzuelo para atraer estudiantes porque
como bien los dígitos pablo los
estudiantes extranjeros aquí como en
cualquier parte del mundo pagan sus
estudios y una forma de atraerlos o de
ofrecerles un anzuelo más hasta el cual
se definió en algunas notas
periodísticas era ofrecerles esta la
posibilidad de obtener la residencia
permanente y posteriormente la
ciudadanía una vez culminado sus
estudios obtenido el diploma y con una
formación ya acreditada
en áreas que son necesarias para el
funcionamiento de la economía provincial
desaparecido este anzuelo este atractivo
muchas universidades ya han expresado su
preocupación ante la posibilidad de que
la matrícula de estudiantes extranjeros
que llaman una parte muy importante de
la matriz general de los ingresos de
esas instituciones sea el centro de
formación profesional de este que no te
hable hace un rato el 80 por ciento de
la de la camada donde estuviera persona
que lo conozco son de afuera y están
pagando fortunas para estar ahí cuesta
un centro de fotografía 25 mil dólares
por un curso de 1800 horas que es lo que
se requiere es el mínimo 1800 horas de
estudio para un diplomático listo para
que te puedan dar
el diploma y para que te puedan dar el
certificado bueno la disputa sigue no
hay nada definido al respecto como pablo
decía como la mesa decía hace unos
instantes el ministro de inmigración ha
aparentemente regulado en sus
intenciones pero como decía también
nuestro invitado esa marcha atrás es
parcial porque la ley la iniciativa
sigue en pie y sigue avanzando así que
seguiremos en los próximos días viendo
qué sucede con este tema esperando que
se resuelva de la mejor manera posible y
sobre todo esperando que no se le quite
a los estudiantes extranjeros que han
puesto su atención y su mirada en las
universidades quebequenses la la
intención las ganas de venir se irán a
una universidad anglófona fuera de que
bueno ontario ya hay gente ayer salió
diciendo
si las provincias del este también es un
regalo real más piense en una cosa
porque eso es lo peor es muy grave lo
que estaba pasando con una
retroactividad pero con este plan con
esta ley en la cual van a modificar la
lista a todos los años si entonces yo
tengo estudiar arquitectura que está en
la lista
me como mis cuatro cinco o seis años
para terminar mis estudios arquitectura
en el mundo que termine arquitectura
nuestra masa en la lista
a donde voy donde además van a reconocer
mi título no no es realmente pero no
terminaba ahí la presión sigue porque
están los rectores de universidades
colegios e instituciones que dicen que
todos los que normalmente no estamos de
acuerdo
estemos contra la ley bueno vamos a
seguir con el tema y con quién vamos a
seguir hablando también es que nuestro
invitado que ya se lanzó para sí no
[Risas]
como decíamos al comienzo damián ni
reason es músico es de origen argentino
se fue de la argentina hace muchos años
antes de llegar a canadá viviste en
suiza
en realidad vivían suiza durante el
gobierno militar
viví ocho años de suiza siendo muy joven
entre los 18 y los 26
y de polis argentinas me volvía a ir
pero al par de meses antes de que iba a
ser padre en argentina volvió otra vez a
argentina y en realidad no pasé casi
unos 20 años en argentina entre mis dos
argentinas
vivíamos en san luís y mi papá lo tenía
que operar formosa buenos aires me tuvo
en ese momento pero decir que es porteño
y también en el 2004 cerradicas t
en canadá qué fue lo que te atrajo que
lo que te trajo mejor dicho a canadá
el clima básicamente el clima de este y
la putin no ciertamente no
en realidad para ser sincero la primera
idea cuando fue el desastre a fin del
en argentina con paul y mi mujer
decidimos que nos queríamos ir realmente
estamos el nivel de fatiga y de ansiedad
y de dolor que nos produjo la situación
vamos a frenar la salvación o que no se
recuerda del tema que nos siga el tema o
la realidad argentina en particular que
en el 2001 se dio una de las crisis
financieras más graves que debió
enfrentar el país aparte de la salida de
lo que se llamaba en ese momento
corralito es una pretensión que se hacía
de los ahorros en dólares en los bancos
y la gente ante la imposibilidad de
retirar su dinero los bancos en dólares
y empezó el ipec eso es también es
cierto salió a casa y rodear como se
decía en aquel momento salió a protestar
contra los bancos y una crisis política
cada grande quiso caer un body nanciera
social fue en realidad no logramos
acordar el primer banco que decidió no
reembolsar los ahorros en su coche les
cause evans y después siguieron todos y
obviamente con el apoyo del gobierno
pero la realidad generación dijimos
vámonos y volver a suiza donde yo había
vivido muchos años pero hacía mucho
tiempo ya
posible las condiciones legales habían
cambiado totalmente y no me veía
viajando en ese momento yo tenía tres
hijas
cuando nos vinimos para acá la más joven
tenía diez meses después tuvimos una
cuarta nacida acá nos dimos cuenta que
lo que hubiéramos podido hacer si éramos
una pareja sola no lo queríamos hacer
con nuestras hijas porque ellas están
volando y esperando a que la cuestión
legal se resuelva
y nos enteramos que acá en canadá el
régimen era mucho más benigno régimen
que grosso modo sigue siendo el mismo si
bien la debida modificación es un
régimen de puntos
lo intentamos funcionó nos encantó y de
hecho tuvimos un momento particularmente
emocionante en medio del desastre que
era la vida en argentina en ese momento
que fue nuestra entrevista con el
delegado del gobierno de quebec en
buenos aires
un hijo de inmigrantes húngaros a quien
después encontré acá muchos años después
que terminada la entrevista
desata el nudo de su corbata y nos dice
bueno tengo el placer de decirles que en
el nombre del gobierno de la provincia
de québec ustedes son aceptados como
inmigrantes y qué
entonces nos encanta la gente como
ustedes
salimos del hotel nos fuimos a la plaza
enfrente a llorar los dos
y digamos nos pareció tan increíble que
un oficial de inmigración pudiera
hablarnos en esos términos y en un
momento que era tan duro nosotros
habíamos perdido prácticamente todo en
el corralito como muchísimo otra gente
no era mucho lo que teníamos pero era lo
único y la verdad que fue un hermoso
comienzo y fue un comienzo que no fue
para nada desmentido por la realidad una
vez que llegamos acá ahora tu actividad
central damián es la de murcia tóxica
eras músico ya en argentina seguir
siendo un negocio no murió acá sos multi
instrumentista aunque real lo que te
define más es el saxo es depende porque
depende de qué lado me conozcan digamos
yo tengo mi cuarteto instrumental para
el cual yo compongo música inspirada de
tradiciones judías de europa del este-
música jacint y acá es básicamente un
grupo de jazz tener
no es tan klezmer está más inspirado en
la música litúrgica y en la música
jacinta este menos festiva más
contemplativa y bueno en todo caso ese
es un rubro en otros rubros que yo
compongo canciones en español que están
muchas veces basadas
en ritmos tradicionales argentinos
y eso en otro grupo que se llama sol
agua mis composiciones en general
aterrizan en los discos de este mundo
así que juego en ambos lados y soy actor
y soy director de una compañía de
creación
exactamente quería preguntar porque
cuando me respondiste mi primer mail más
tarde me enviaste otro donde decía y
olvidé decir que soy actor pero para los
que somos argentinos tienen peso grande
porque el tocaba en un grupo que marcó
la adolescencia de mucha gente en
argentina o sea tocaba con pipo pipo
cipolatti pozzi polat y que sí que es un
gran músico y realmente fue un fue una
época la música de pipo y cuando lo
conocí hace 10 12 15 años atrás era como
cosas
estoy al lado de alguien la música de
cipolletti indirecta es enrola
directamente lo que es rock es pop
no tiene nada que ver con los estilos a
los que después te sumaste en no después
yo ya tenía esa vida digamos la música
yo hice siempre fue esta música
invendible
pero cuando volví a argentina en el 84
85 muy rápidamente me empezaron a llamar
bandas de rock lo cual me permitió vivir
pero siempre mantuve esa especie de
corriente ahí marginal
que en algún momento se volvió un
poquito más popular al menos mis
creaciones que no eran rock se volvió
más populares porque me había hecho
conocer como músico de rock entonces
había gente que no tenía idea que era la
música y los jazz que venían los shows y
que a la salida de acción me esperaban
para decirme me encantó por no tenía
idea que esta música existía este a lo
cual se respondió eso tampoco pero pero
no hoy por suerte en argentina hay
digamos la gente consume arte si es que
sea teatro y cada vez que voy no deja de
sorprenderme ver pequeñas salas de
teatro rellenas pequeños bares llenos
mientras un grupo bueno o no tan bueno
está tocando a la gente para la gente es
importante estar cerca es lo que esta
producto estoy fe hablábamos la semana
pasada aquí de que yo estuve un mes en
septiembre en buenos aires después de
muchos años de no ir y fui a ver
muchísimos van muchísimos fui a ver
varios espectáculos no necesariamente
masivos todos como uno puede suponer que
no es masivo el tango que hace daniel
melingo por ejemplo y cuando fui a verlo
alseseca el centro cultural
estaba repleto de gente
viste el show con isabel de sebastián si
estuviese presente hay dios ayudante
inteligente la nieta de don felipe
yo quería agregar que ese cerco
argentino del cual les hable
[Risas]
la bienvenida
muchas gracias cómo está tu bienvenido
aquí gracias si tener un mensaje a la
gente que nos está mirando directamente
en facebook que dice hola desde
argentina mirada con paulo duarte dice
buenas tardes amigos desde el sur de
portugal daniel campo line saludo mundo
argentina una obra sobre distancia gusta
luca dice saludos de la ciudad de melo
departamento de cerro largo en uruguay
mañana sábado participar en un evento en
buenos aires con los gerentes directivos
presentadores de la emisión
internacional sería bueno realizar algo
con radio canadá internacional del mismo
estilo dice gustavo sería muy
interesante gustavo después hablaremos a
ver qué se pasea paulo arte sobre star
es amigos desde el suelo portugal viendo
aquí la emisión en vivo
bueno después hay una charla entre ellos
que la pueden ver en el fin de nuestra
de nuestra red social
y gustavo no para isabel zamora dice
saludos a todos los locutores mercedes
alaya radio taiwán internacionales la
sal sin mando de esa charla que parece
que es esa radio que fue a buenos aires
a hacer una
una muestra supongo y mercedes a la dice
pero hay que escuchar radios
internacionales para informarnos y sigue
la charla vamos a ver entonces si hay
más mensajes en este caso todo se ha
entablado con respecto a la información
que había dictado
[Música]
si no me equivoco no es no gustavo tavo
lucas con la presencia de radio taiwán
internacional en buenos aires y damián
mayor es decir habitualmente los músicos
tienen su grupo o más ser tienen una
formación principal y otra formación
complementaria pero aquí en los datos
que vos mismo me enviaste veo que
participas en distintas formaciones no
sean por un lado solá agua que la
nombraste gauchitos la fanfare grupo
porque fue el criminal sic y friends por
radio tango
[Risas]
pasan varias cosas esto no conocer es
aquí no se tocan todos los días entonces
tiempo tenemos este no oye en realidad
como músico profesional
tanto acá como en argentina yo creo que
eso es una imagen
un poco parcial que uno puede tener de
lo que hacen los músicos esto que hemos
decir con respecto a los músicos de rock
por ejemplo es habitual pero en otros
medios como por ejemplo en el medio del
jazz es muy frecuente que estemos
colaborando si montón de músicos y es
más que a uno lo llamen a mí me pasa
cada tanto me llaman la última hora para
decirme el saxofonista quedó varado con
marian
super pianista dice mi saxofonistas
quedó varado en la ruta voy a tocar un
bar a tres cuadras de tu casa podés
venir vos no conozco el repertorio no
conozco los temas vamos
digamos las cosas funcionan de otra
manera no sé en qué vos nombraste es mi
cuarteto de música instrumental solo
toca mis composiciones solo agua somos
una banda de verdad cosa que acá es rara
si no hay un líder y hay más o menos la
mitad del repertorio son composiciones
mías y las otras son todas bandas de las
que soy miembro
qué es
un milagro de la naturaleza pura poesía
es una cosa increíble que existe bajo
distintos nombres desde los años 70 en
montreal
y era 12 años me llamo para reemplazar
un saxofonista después me dejamos para
reemplazar a otro y un día me llaman y
veo que todos los saxofonistas están
dije uy
parece que soy miembro nunca nadie me lo
dijo pero hace ya por lo menos 10 años
que tocó con ellos de manera permanente
y grabamos discos y hacemos giras por
europa y es el paraíso y por estos días
están participando de un ciclo musical
de otoño que no termina el 9 mañana
termina mañana
en realidad termina pasado mañana ahora
le voy a explicar mañana no toco yo dios
mi compañía produce dos bandas de
jóvenes montreal es extraordinarias
ambas dos bar nacho que hace una especie
de son composiciones propias pero en un
espíritu muy georges brassens palabras
divinas muy buenos músicos y todos entre
los 20 y los 25 años esas cosas que no
hay que perderse porque es el futuro y
la otra es una banda instrumental que es
avances que altera el que la dirige un
compositor saxofonista clarinetista
flautista otro milagro de naturaleza es
el llanto más si tipo de 27 años que
vino a hacer sus estudios de música acá
uno de esos talentos que con esta nueva
ley nos perderíamos este el tipo es un
virtuoso es una palabra que yo no
utilizo mucho no más de una vez por día
tocas
no no no pero realmente esos tipos
escuchas
yo no sabía que había tantas notas no
tienes buen gusto y bueno es una especie
de pequeña phan fah pequeña fanfarria de
seis músicos que hace son los valses que
él compone bellísimo así que eso es lo
que va a ver mañana en la vitrola y el
domingo ganchitos pero el este que somos
en realidad thomas jensen súper músico
nacido en argentina es fue de argentina
a los 6 años y yo sus canciones y mil
canciones juntos en norias díaz lacava
en un lugar muy bonito con sus hijas y
con una de las mías
hacemos un bonito show de canciones en
español
en radio canadá internacional ahora
y preparadas además cardón pablo prepara
además una actuación para los primeros
días de febrero en buenos aires en
febrero nos en mi cuarteto instrumental
va a viajar por primera vez a argentina
porque yo generalmente voy o voy solo o
voy con tomás este y logre este año que
conseguir contratos en buenos aires-
contratos
visto desde acá horrible pero son
contratos y mis músicos que ve cos
desde que tocamos juntos hace 15 años
que quieren ir vamos a argentina aunque
sea para comer un asado
eso está bueno pero con un asado asado
chicles y vino tinto eso van a tener y
el público de allá que no te conozca que
el repertorio puede esperar en esas
actuaciones
es una buena pregunta este está definido
lo que hacemos conocen lo que hemos
hecho con nos hemos hecho cuatro discos
desde que yo llegué acá este y es
básicamente siempre son composiciones
hechas pero con una impronta muy fuerte
judía en las melodías y en la armonía de
los temas pero si hay que catalogar los
galanes básicamente jazz y donde vamos a
tocar son lugares de jazz me interesó lo
que tú decías tú tienes una de sus hijas
va a tocar contigo que instrumentó esto
que hace mi hija miranda buenos otros
cuatro hijas la mayor vive en barcelona
y es bailarina y acróbata la de 19 años
la que va a tocar conmigo el domingo y
que toco conmigo según la semana también
la vitrola
es guitarrista y violinista y cantante
tiene una voz angelical como la mía
eran cantantes de vida conociste a
miranda chiquita bueno ahora tiene 19
años y mi estatura vista desde acá no es
chiquita
y las otras 2 dalila 16 años muy buenos
violinistas y nicky de 13 un desastre en
casi todo proto camuy bien el cello es
la música que grita en los genes y
vieron que uno puede hacerse rico con la
música
me escuchan a mí o practicando o tocando
y hay algo que es una postura filosófica
yo siempre me dije yo lo único que tengo
en la vida tiene que mi padre murió
cuando yo era niño muy joven
quiero vivir una vida que esté hecha de
placer no quiero pasar ocho horas por
día haciendo algo que no me gusta para
los 65 años jubilarme e ir ahora al golf
no digo que eso sea malo no era bueno
para mí no podía de hecho yo hice
estudios de historia en la universidad
podría ser profesor de historia en un
sello en la universidad
no pasa por ahí para mí lo mío es la
música y cada minuto que le dedico a la
música sobre todo desde el día que
decidí que no era capaz de tocar con
alguien con quien no me gustaría
sentarme a tomar una copa de vino tinto
es muy buena decisión la voy a miriam
alarcón pregunta puedo encontrar música
del entrevistado en spotify sé
a mi nombre oa nombre de los grupos en
realidad les recomiendo más vancamp que
spotify pero sobre spotify están todos
mis discos ahí vamos a poner entonces el
nombre completo de damián para cómo se
escribe para que puedan buscar música en
spotify y en banca también y para ir
cerrando este tramo en todo caso del
programa proyectos discográficos
proyecto es bueno en realidad yo acabo
de sacar un disco de música instrumental
hace exactamente un año y un disco con
sola agua de canciones en español este
hace seis meses fin de abril con lo que
en este momento discos míos no pero si
estoy realizando discos en mi compañía
malas artes produce justamente
grabaciones de calidad de músicas
invendibles nuestras condiciones y lo
logró
y tenemos varios discos justamente en el
disco de 6 que altera de este trío de
este sexteto de vals es en principio es
algo que vamos a grabar en marzo próximo
patrick ryan un excelente posiblemente
el más importante percusionista de
música étnica en montreal va a ser su
primer disco solista ese disco también
lo vamos a grabar el transcurso del
invierno así que son proyectos muy muy
muy interesantes que es unas cosas me
encanta de montreal poder hacer cosas
independientemente del valor comercial
que puedan tener el apoyo del dinero
público es muy importante para crear
arte de calidad
y ese arte de calidad que de alguna
manera termina también metiéndose con el
tiempo en el mainstream un poco lo que
pasa con la fórmula uno atrás y los
autos que nosotros manejamos hoy nos
encontramos con cosas que hace 20 años
estaban los autos de fórmula uno
solamente y ahora también entonces se
trata entonces como decíamos de damián
siguen son nisenson perdón
ya no lo compraban todos se lo buscan
por el nombre que te dio luis no te va
ni nosotros sino también me pueden
encontrar con mi seudónimo charly garcía
[Risas]
entonces a quién le agradecemos tu
presencia aquí no te vas te invitamos a
que permanezcan los pocos minutos que
nos restan de nuestro programa y te
deseamos mucho éxito en las
presentaciones que tienen tras este fin
de semana aquí en sus presentaciones
previstas para buenos aires el próximo
año y los proyectos que
en el corto plazo con toda seguridad
siendo multifacético e inquieto como se
nota imposible estar detenido esta es mi
naturaleza muchas gracias por invitarme
muchas gracias a vos y yo le voy a pedir
a leonardo si tiene la posibilidad de
acceder a nuestra aplicación móvil que
nos recuerde aunque sea sucintamente de
qué se trata así en los aquellos que
quieran consultar nuestro sitio a través
de su teléfono
así es en realidad pueden bajar las de
las dos tiendas más importantes estas
son la tienda de apple en la tienda
playstation y pueden escribir radio
canadá internacional en español y sale
nuestra aplicación es una manera mucho
más rápida y fiable de poder entrar y
ver el contenido que produce el equipo
latinoamericano también para que los que
vivan en canadá que hablen más de una
lengua o que vean afuera hable más de
una lengua pueden encontrar contenidos
en las dos lenguas oficiales a partir de
la nueva instancia la aplicación de
español y pueden entrar a las últimas
entrevistas y reportajes y noticias del
equipo en inglés y en francés de radio
cada internacional perfecto nos queda un
poquito más de cinco minutos así que
vamos a aprovecharlos para presentarle a
nuestro público los diversos temas en
los que hemos estado trabajando durante
esta semana ha estado muy silenciosa
paloma entonces de que tengo mucho que
decir si esta semana les quiero proponer
que escuche en una entrevista que hice
con maría angélica cuervo maría angélica
cuervo es una de las actrices que
participa en la versión latina de el
diario de anna frank que está haciendo
se está siendo presentado da en
vancouver en el marco de un festival que
se llama chupa chups para en vancouver
entonces un reparto latino que fue
formado en los ángeles maría angélica
cuervo es colombiana canadiense pero
vive en los ángeles y entonces allá fue
reclutada digamos para eso
para este reparto la tintos presentan el
diario de anna frank con una visión
pensando en el mundo en el xi con el que
estamos viviendo de las caravanas
migrantes de alguna manera están shimmer
zimmerman que es el realizador de mando
el realizador el director de la escribe
si me tocan centre no existe una
traducción exacta en español es el
director de la obra o el estreno de la
puesta en escena exactamente decidió que
quería darle una visión un poco más
actual a este a este diario que marcó la
vida y la adolescencia de mucha gente
entre otras la mía entonces bueno
conocer la historia de esta joven judía
a través de este reparto latino
yo lo voy a dejar que la lean
directamente porque tiene que ver
recibió un montón yo todavía no lo
entiendo bien así que imaginen a la
gente que está del otro lado e intente
entenderlo y si tienen algún punto para
esclarecer por favor háganlo por el caso
se habla de una computadora exacto que
jugué la pasada
y había encontrado la computadora que
trabaja con los qubits y no los bits que
trabajamos nosotros normalmente es una
computadora supercomputadora mucho más
rápida una computadora cuántica que es
la palabra todo lo que sea cuántico
nadie lo entiende salvo la gente que lo
hace
en este caso es eso google dijo hemos
logrado la computadora cuántica salieron
un par diciendo no no están así hay una
pequeña discusión y presentando de qué
se trata esta computadora y por qué
funciona una vez a manny computadora que
puede hacer en 200 segundos operaciones
que la computadora más avanzada
existente en este momento le llevaría
diez mil años hacer exactamente y bueno
esa es una de las discusiones porque
puntualmente ibm dijo que no están así
que no es tan tan tan así y explican por
qué pero en realidad sería un cambio
realmente increíble en lo que nosotros
conocemos de computación a viajes más
rápida en todo caso rápido los escasos
dos minutos y pico que nos quedan bueno
muy rápidamente louis esta semana
comenzó aquí en quebec
una comisión especial sobre la
explotación sexual de menores
es formada por 13 diputados de todos los
partidos de la asamblea nacional aquí
hablamos de la provincia de québec
exacto y bueno entonces resulta de que
fuera de la provincia de québec y las
niñas que se prostituyen que en esta
comisión de las que aman más bien
víctimas ellos dicen no son prostitutas
son víctimas y los que se llaman
clientes no son clientes son abusadores
de menores si entonces pues estas niñas
por ser de lengua francesa de habla
francesa son muy buscadas fuera de la
provincia de québec entonces
hay una explotación sexual increíble
algo que me dejó pasmado decía dice en
esta comisión que un proxeneta que tiene
bajo su control a cinco o seis niñas
como estas víctimas les deja a esta
persona entre 200.000 y 300.000 dólares
anuales entonces pues es un negocio muy
lucrativo y yo le quiere poner términos
ese negocio perfecto yo por mi lado les
ofrezco un reportaje que hice el lunes
último sobre un estudio
multidisciplinario que se llevó a cabo
en todo canadá que detectó que el agua
potable de diversas ciudades canadienses
entre ellas por ejemplo montreal tiene
niveles de contaminación con plomo que
supera el caso conocido famoso de la
ciudad de flint en michigan en los eeuu
que a principios de los años 2000 se
transformó en un escándalo por la mala
calidad del agua además a era un
escándalo por la situación económica que
vivía esa ciudad de la crisis financiera
total y que fue reflejada por el
cineasta michael moore en una de sus
películas más afamadas hay ciudades en
canadá que tienen niveles de
contaminación con plomo superiores a los
que se detectaron perdón y no nos queda
más tiempo
javier gonzález nungaray que de votarse
a los a todos si hay una linda propuesta
y que hagamos un programa semanal digo
para alguna de poder o por día
y les agradecemos a todos ustedes haber
estado presentes una vez más a través de
los diversos canales de comunicación que
tienen a su disposición les ofrecemos
que se vuelvan a encontrar con nosotros
en 7 días más y por el momento
muchísimas gracias y buen otoño casi
invierno